anyway yes yes yes and meaning how do I
move no way you start the game I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna teach you good I'm
gonna win all right - I don't stop
giving a [ __ ] oh god you guys are
terrible
oh god they're all moving now what are
they doing they have to be what are you
taking the ball Ken oh yeah you're
destroying my goal
well I guess my guys wants to party hey
wait
how's that a draw it's clearly me I got
your guys humping the ball that's
disturbing
Jesus okay yes all right oh [ __ ] I
selected the wrong size of the goal I'm
a huge ball
oh that you oh damn I thought it was me
Oh so high that ball
I'm gonna get it you can't escape my
guys don't touch me don't touch me don't
touch me don't touch me will you go and
get dammit that's a terrible idea
my ball haha my ball dhf it's my ball
what it is pickable site Oh God good job
Ken good job what we did it what did you
do I didn't do anything
yeah you did maybe the score goal should
be a little bigger maybe just maybe
oh I should I make it as big as you can
all right well I'm waiting for you you
scrub I'm right I'm bread I'm gonna
score go kick it kick it kick it goddamn
it
alright number two has to do this oh
yeah oh yeah kick it kick it kick it
kick it kick it it's the free your open
your own bed tackle em come on don't
tackle this is not rugby all right this
is gentleman's point this is American
American football is that what you call
it you just have to put American in
there America Foley had some barbecue
all right okay here we go if only it
were no barbecue for you [ __ ] that's
the ball oh yes yes yes yeah that was
intense
that was intense I was on the line
that's recalling Sweden I don't know we
don't say that
all right see kick wits face I guess I
should share that with you I think the
ball hits me more anything don't you see
that front flip down sounds nice okay
dude do you think I do anything you're
not great for pull the grace
yes name show grace no grace yes that's
my new channel name don't hi guys this
is stop they pissed me off so much
sometimes excuse me this one got the
grass like Nick don't give that don't
that's not your leg that's not football
at all that's it
oh come on we're never gonna find that
button a ball is lost forever and you
know yeah dang it
I guess I'll cross the street it's too
painful I can't watch this
all right if this doesn't if you don't
score this time catch right go wow what
a kick
stop the ball come on he was luckily
place there kick him kick him
oh man it's my turn this is me when when
I was a kid and finally got the ball
this is my chance this is your chance
don't my Roma this is my finally all
eyes on me
how will I do fantastic are you trying
to get over here cuz you I had pants and
don't scizor me don't sister me get on
Becca bro are you talking about yeah
kick it kick it nice at least they're
not humping each other my guys got left
if there's anything wrong with it don't
mind me I'm just just down the harder
they try you try the more you fail it
just stands up and just falls backwards
you can't handle it can we just take a
moment and appreciate how great their
assets are they're really round and firm
like someone took two fun hams and stuck
them down the back of my pants that's
probably and that's probably what
happened we just clear these guys out of
the way now because okay one at a time
let's have that make a better rule my
guys stuck like he's literally stuck
there and I think great guys suck too
and I think they both very much you like
it you smell that
oh yes it smells like like Christmas I
had tuna oh yeah definitely Christmas
come on move that ball move the damn
ball all right whoever wins this wins
the World Cup this is Sweden versus
America and America go Sweden Sweden
[Music]
I got a clue this ball we got attack
attack oh it's another one all right one
zero God bring your A game next time or
something oh so well you press space you
Lunars dancer the ground hug me
well with that what happened they all
right I guess this man go go so bad he's
so bad pain I thought you were a mochi -
good ball
no no no no no don't let don't you're on
to it the ball you want to fall over you
want to fall over that's what you want
to do oh god I don't know what is your
idea oh come on come on come on oh my
god
3-0 really Ken shut up Gamow [ __ ] get a
rake ball
my guys are laughing at you did you
realize oh wow nice blocked again like
that oh lucky and see ah amazing I think
he's just dying early he's getting in a
coma someone told him this is an
American football he just went to a coma
he wanted become a wall he doesn't want
to be hit football play he can't take me
on the team anymore well he's doing a
great job at being at wall I got this
thing
maybe that's the tactic you should go
back he's back his wife will be so
relieved now
get it in come on yes again because I
can't stop oh my god
oh no I fell what are you guys doing is
this alright it's safe to say that I won
that one
let's do another one before you start
crying I've already cried f tears I
really their from laughing they're not
from the top from there nothing crud I
don't know one believes you can't let's
be honest here Oh God
alright are you ready for this I was
born ready for this bring it [ __ ]
oh I think I'm winning it'd be amazing
Resco actually score my god would it
happen again
[Music]
just just throw enough money and people
at it and you'll win that's the American
Way you should be very proud I'm proud
ken for president things
[Music]
brofist